Hi everyone, in this lesson we're going to take a look briefly at PCGs and we're going to break these up into three different sections in which we'll also later on take a look at blueprints and the foliage tool.
Now these are going to be high level looks at these tools up close and the fact that we already have classes on these so we're just going to do a quick brief summary of how to use them to build your worlds.
So let's go and dive right in.
One of the first things you want to do is turn on our PCG tool in our plugins. Let's go and jump into Unreal and I'll show you what I'm talking about.
So in Unreal, let's go ahead. Mine's already turned on but I'm going to go ahead and do it here. We're just going to mock it. Go to our plugins and we're going to type in PCG.
With our PCG you'll notice the main one we want to turn on is our procedural content generation framework.
Now you're more than welcome to experiment with these others such as the content generation framework, external data, interlope, interrope I should say, and procedural content generation framework geometry script.
These things are optional if you want to play with them. We're not doing geometry script in this particular class. We do have classes for that.
Also the other ones such as the bio meme and the bio mean core. You want to be careful with these. They are experimental. These experimental on one such as with the Niagara PCG Niagara.
So I don't recommend them for shipping your product but just keep that thing. Keep those things in mind. Experiment with them see if that maybe be might be something that you want to use a later on.
It's up to you. But we're mainly going to be living here and working with this. Let me go to close.
So you'll see that I have a PCG in here and I also have a spline outline of where I want my trees to go. It's not contained in a box which you'll see a lot of the times when it comes to terrain.
This one's more based on spline. Let me show you what I mean. So one of the first things you want to do is you want to right click and I'm just going to go in my content folder and do this generally.
And we're going to go to our PCG area. I'm going to turn on PCG graph and that's pretty much what I did. And I saw and I select the default empty graph.
So when I created that default empty graph I made sure that I also created a spline curve first. So I'm going to go ahead and I did a draw spline using my modeling mode here.
And in my modeling mode I did the draw spline. And when I drew the spline I made sure that it was looped when I did it. And I made sure that it was a tangent that was usable for me or the ones that depends what you're used to or what you want the spline to look like.
You're more than welcome to play with these settings. And then you can choose how you want it to overall be viewed and controlled later on.
So once I was done with that I hit accept I'm going to cancel here because we're not doing it because I already have it. This one's a little bit less of a curve and more linear with its points.
But it's whatever you want to do when you build it out. Once it is built though this is where things are key. Once you build your PCG graph you drag it into your scene.
Let's pull that PCG graph up. And we want to make sure that we go under settings graph instance and instance. Now this isn't intuitive like you have to open these up to be able to get to it.
I've had students ask a lot where I go to get this where's the icon to open up the blueprint like features. This is pretty much where you go. And I'm going to double click on that call that up. Let's pull this into our scene. Let's go full screen.
And I kept this pretty basic and the fact that we have a get spline data. Now we're not getting the height information. We're not doing that in this particular case. We're not grabbing that terrain information. We're just getting the spline data and keep it in a box and you can do it either way.
This I find works pretty nice if you just want a general sense and control. Maybe you want to scatter rocks on a street. This works out pretty well. That's not based on terrain.
So we just have a sample here spline sampler. You'll notice we have two to play with here if we wanted to. I have it so it breaks off and you have this option you can play with if you want to. If you wanted to make it so that it's a spline creating a path in this little generic forest you can do that.
Now what is allowing this to work is a call a thing called a player tag. The get spline data is going to get our information. It's like blueprints where you can get or set. In this case I'm getting the information and in that I created a player tag called demo team. So it knows that it's referencing that information.
And in that towards the back end we have like distance self pruning. You don't necessarily have to use self pruning. I'll show you an alternative for that. There's a transform points and there's union. And again there's a difference. And again that's where the if you wanted to make a path would come in. There's no player tag on this or spline to associate yet.
But you're more than welcome to play with that. And then finally we have our static mesh spawner in which I'm loading all the different pieces of geometry. And now that was pieces of geometry will be attached to the player tag of that spline which is again demo team. Now if I go into my real scene you'll see if we go to the spline object here.
So make sure we select him and not the floor. I'm going to zoom in a little bit. I might have just already had him selected maybe. Well then again I had the PCG selected.
There we go. So with him selected we can now look at the tag for him and you'll see that he's called demo team. And that works out pretty well. So PCG knows that when in this spline curves in this region that it will draw and shape things. I should say populate the mesh in my spline curve because it knows that information and what I want to do based on the nodes that I've connected.
So we also can see on a micro and macro level. Here's my PCG shape which is quite big given you room to play with if you wanted to. But I can also expand it if I wanted to. It looks like our geometry is going to get jacked up but it does adjust itself which is nice.
And then if I wanted to I can go in here and grab my points of articulation in my spline curve and make things out a little bit more with that more broad opening of my PCG.
And that's a nice thing because it's almost like you're working on a macro and a micro level. So micro being the spline curve and macro being the larger PCG encompassing our spline.
Cool. So that's a quick way to get things populated in a particular region. We'll look at the one working with terrain. The thing you do have to keep in mind is this does not solve all problems when you have like a little say you have a bunch of rubble that you need to handle maybe some books even on the floor and you're using this particular one because it's not based on terrain.
Even in terrain instances these do not solve the issue though of having a lot of geometry because a lot of geometry is always going to be a question.
And what I mean by that is performance because this does not make instancing smoother. It just makes it so that you can encapsulate the instancing.
So instancing with a lot of geometry can be an issue. You want to make sure that you nanite your foliage or whatever object you're messing with. So it makes it easier for calculating. You also keep your eyes open.
Also down the pipe we're going to have it so that you can use voxel based trees. So that's coming soon. And that's going to make it a lot easier to have a larger forest environment.
So this is a really cool tool. This is a really cool tool to work with and it's getting better stronger faster to be able to make things really robust as you start editing and creating material. Awesome.
So let's go ahead and we're going to pop back into the slides real quick. And we're going to take a look at a few things. So in my slides I kind of walk you through some of the steps. You'll notice in the slides it does show more of a terrain based.
We'll talk about that later on. It shows you that there's an input with a surface sampler. This input information allows us to use a landscape height. If I go to the next slide, you'll notice that I have an example of an alternative based on using transform points and random choice.
You can use a difference. This will prevent any overlapping. So if you didn't want to use the prune node, you can also use the difference node. And that actually works pretty well. This is what I meant by it being an alternative to that. So you could run this route if you wanted to.
Now again, we have a full class on this with a full breakdown if you want to dive into this deeper. But I think this gives you a nice taste of what you can do initially when it comes to building your world.
You just got to keep in mind where things are at. What is a higher priority? What can I get away with and fool the audience, the ones playing my game? What can I do to make them believe this world is robust without necessarily making ridiculous amounts of trees that may not may or may not necessarily need to be there. You could use rocks and other larger structures to maybe hide where those areas might be lacking. So keep all those things in mind.
That's it with this one. In the next video, we're going to take a look at blueprints up close and how to use them and the best approaches you need to keep in mind when building your game world. Thanks again.